so on this edition of the scoutmaster podcast we're going to do something a little different
i'm off to camp this week wanted to record the podcast have it set up and ready to go for you
while i'm away so how about a summer music special one of the frequent comments i get
is that people really enjoy the music on the podcast and i got to tell you so do i
it's a lot of fun finding tunes that are related to scouting or our songs that we sing around the
campfire or in the dining hall or something like that so uh yeah i've been hunting down stuff and
i just thought it might be fun we'll spend this podcast listening to some of the music and i'll
give you an idea of where it came from and uh who who's who's done it so start out with this one
this is the best version of this song that i think i've ever heard i hope you agree
i'm a little deep i'm short and stout here is my handle here is my spout when i get all steamed up
then i shout tip me over and pull me out tip me over and pull me out tip me over and pull me out
yeah that's carlton godwin from uh an album called uh jazz baby session three now the these are songs
like you know pretty familiar songs that have been recorded by some um musicians with some real
chops and it's been put together and you're going to play it for the kids at home for the babies and
the kids and whatever but i think it's too cool just for babies i mean carlton godwin did a did a
great job on that here's another cut from a similar album
so
absolutely the coolest rendition
of the song bingo
isn't that something that is uh thomas moore on an album called twinkle twinkle jazzy star
oh you gotta love it oh what a great tune they did a nice job on it didn't they listen i've got
links to all this on the blog at scoutmaster.typepad.com where you can go and get these songs for yourself
they're either from itunes or from amazon and uh so uh you know support the uh support the musicians
go ahead and get these songs for yourself and you can use them at your next uh scout soiree
or whatever it is um i i'm a jazz aficionado i like jazz and things like that uh here's one that
i have had uh lots of favorable comments
so
now that is a uh called a boy scout in switzerland and if you listen to it carefully you can hear the uh bugle
play and then echo back and uh it's just a really cool piece of music and it was composed by a fellow named raymond scott
raymond scott was a composer and a jazz artist and he thought that swing music was getting kind of stagnant and so he worked in
so
so that's called a boy scout in switzerland and it's by composer raymond scott now
you've heard raymond scott's music but
probably not as he first intended
he was a composer in the 1930s who thought swing music was getting kind of stagnant and it was kind of being stamped out uh one after another and so he decided he wanted to write some music with some real heart to it and some real musicianship and so he he uh composed a lot of these uh things for his uh sextet or quintet i think and then they went on uh later on to be adopted and used in the background of a lot of cartoons and the
in the background of a lot of cartoons.
So when you listen to that music, you're thinking,
wow, it sounds kind of like the background to a Bugs Bunny cartoon or something like that.
Well, a lot of his music ended up that way.
But he didn't really originally intend it that way.
And I found that version by the Bo Hunk's Sextet on iTunes.
But I played it out because I just think it's a great piece of music.
I found some other pieces of music that aren't jazz
and that are only tangentially related to Scouts.
But I think they're just great fun.
And here's one.
Boy Scouts!
So this I just found looking around on iTunes.
It's by a group called Maintain Composure.
I think they're from Ohio.
You know, I tried to email them and, like, ask them about the song
because I imagine some of them are Boy Scouts at one time.
It's kind of an interesting song.
But I never got a reply.
So if they're listening, let me know.
Here's another one that I found that is really kind of unusual.
And it's from a group in Norway called the Shitses.
I think it's like the dog, you know, the Shih Tzu.
So, but it just really tickled me.
And I've used it a few times on the podcast.
He's my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
You're my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
You were always on the Beat Boy, Beat Boy.
Yeah, you were always on the Beat Boy, Beat Boy.
I'm hanging in the street, what a street boy.
We were dancing to the Beat Boy, Beat Boy.
Yeah, you're my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
You're my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
He's my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
So, yeah, isn't that a hook?
The full track is great.
I must say, I edit these down to be used, like, in between features on the podcast and things.
But, yeah, if that did something for you, definitely get it off of iTunes because it's great.
The one before that, I don't know if I said that that was called the Boy Scout Boogie.
And, again, that's by a group called Maintain Composure.
It's on iTunes, too.
Here's one that's a little more traditional.
Oh, the rush is old.
Oh, what is your twelve, oh?
Twelve for the twelve apostles.
Eleven for the eleven that went to heaven.
And ten for the Ten Commandments.
Nine for the nine bright shiners.
And eight for the April rainers.
Seven for the seven stars in the sky.
Six for the six-pound walkers.
Five for the cymbals at your door.
And four for the gospel makers.
Three, three.
The rivals.
Two, two.
The lily white boys.
Carved all in green.
Oh, one is one and all alone.
And nevermore shall be so.
Valdery.
Valdera.
Come join my happy song.
Okay, I bet you don't know who that was, but that was Louis Prima,
who was a jazz trumpeter and a fixture on the Las Vegas Strip for many, many years.
You might know him because he did Just a Gigolo, but there he's doing the theme song, The Happy Wanderer.
I don't know really why I chose it, probably because I found this particular incarnation of it.
It just seemed to be a lot of fun.
So let's give a listen to Brave Combo.
You're probably familiar with part of this, but here's Brave Combo with The Happy Wanderer.
I love to go wandering along the mountain track.
And when I go, I love to sing my knapsack on my back.
Valerie, Valerie, Valerie, Valerie, Valerie, Valerie, Valerie, Valerie, Valerie, Valerie, Valerie,
Valerie, Valerie, my knapsack on my back.
So that's the one we use for the theme.
And then there's these guys somewhere out west, I think maybe South Dakota,
who play a more traditional version.
And the reason I like it is because there's lots of cowbell involved.
You've got to love the cowbell, right folks?
I love the cowbell, right folks.
That's a group called the Salzburger Echo.
The Salzburger Echo.
And they're just a lot of fun.
And sometimes you'll hear that in the background of one of the stories on the podcast.
But one last song, or one last version of this song,
and I think that's all that anybody could be expected to take.
But here it is.
The Salzburger Echo.
It's a original rendition by a German symphony orchestra.
And the Happy Wanderer.
Or Mein Wanderer war ein Wanderersmann, if you want it in German.
You know, it's really not an old German folk song.
It was actually written in the late 40s and popularized in the early 50s.
It was written by Friedrich Wilhelm Möller shortly after World War II.
And it just went on to become...
It sounds like a traditional song, doesn't it?
I know it's one that we sing at camp and one that everybody enjoys.
Hey, thanks for listening.
We're going to be back next time with something a little more serious.
But I thought as I was off at camp that, you know,
something kind of fun would make up for the absence.
And we'll talk to you again soon.
Thank you.
Well, thank you for listening to another edition of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This has been podcast number 26.
You can read the Scoutmaster blog at scoutmaster.typepad.com.
And you can follow us at Scoutmaster Blog on Facebook and ScoutmasterCG on Twitter.
Subscribe to the Scoutmaster Podcast on iTunes and feel free to leave a comment or review or rating.
And thanks to those of you who have.
You can email me, Clark Green, with your comments and questions at ClarkGreen at gmail.com.
That's C-L-A-R-K-E-G-R-E-E-N at gmail.com.
The Scoutmaster Blog and the Scoutmaster Podcast are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
No, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to Scout leaders and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
So before we leave you again,
we'd like to hear from
our founder,
Sir Robert.
Thank you, sir.
Thanks again for listening.
And until next time.
.
Thank you.